the [ __ ] am i doing this is my old
Korean grandpa stretches oh hey what is
going on YouTube funny fat pig yes it
has been a while now a lot of you have
been asking where have you been why
haven't you been doing funny fat fit you
left us you fat Korean piece of Shh
that's rude I don't like that but I'm
gonna tell you that funny fat fit has
not stopped I'm still doing it and I'm
here to check up on y'all now for those
you out there who don't know what funny
fat it is or have not been a part of it
let's give y'all a quick rundown roughly
about last year around January or
February I started this thing called
funny fat fit because I wanted to lose
weight and get healthier hmm it was a
way for me to be kept accountable and I
wanted to create a positive community
where you guys could find support in
your weight loss or health journey
though yes I'm still chunky but last
year at around this same time I was 40
pounds heavier
now funny fat fit roughly around
September had a huge setback for me last
year because I had a short film I was
working on and the [ __ ] tank so I say
that without crying
but it's an emotional thing and I also
hurt my ankle again which caused me to
lose a lot of mobility and you know I
went to Hawaii a couple times Christmas
came around Thanksgiving couple Donuts
McDonald's you just know a lot of you
guys out there have been asked me to do
funny fat fit and I read a couple you
guys comments why are you still fat
where's your six-pack don't eat that you
should eat this shut the [ __ ] up I'm
still fat I had no idea haha
yeah because every day I look at the
mirror I was like you know what six-pack
almost there Lacey straight-up my
fitness journey has nothing to do with
what you want for my body haha [ __ ] you
people out there I have told you from
the beginning what you want from your
body and your life this it comes from
what everybody else wants it comes from
what you want out of yourself
[ __ ] what everybody else thinks about
you because the opinion that should
matter the most is yours
no you're not and I see the way that you
talk to other people on the funny fat
fat Instagram
and this channel I'm gonna tell you
right now there's a reason why you have
no friends listen there is a reason why
people constantly tell you to shut the
[ __ ] up
and people have to tell you shut the
[ __ ] up more than seven times a week you
have to realize by now nobody likes you
being concerned and giving people
helpful advice is way different than
bringing somebody down in order to bring
yourself up a lot of the times you guys
out there give advice in order to make
yourself feel better that you know more
than somebody else
what in reality you should know that
you're [ __ ] stupid now the people
that talk like this are usually the ones
that have nothing to show for it some of
the dumbest out of shake lazy
[ __ ] pretty pubescent dumbasses
has the most advice to give you about
health and fitness and a lot of us out
there that's trying to better ourselves
have to ask you this what the [ __ ] do
you know listen you need to stop
googling random facts stop going on
[ __ ] pedia copying something and then
pasting it on somebody else's social
media how are you want to be somebody
else's fitness group when your resume
got a [ __ ] Twinkie and a ham hock on
it listen at the end of the thing this
is what I'm saying if you're gonna talk
about it [ __ ] be about look straight up
I'm still learning listen it's been a
year I've lost 40 pounds and I still
don't know everything there is to know
about fitness
but if FA was never designed to tell you
the best method on how to lose weight I
created funny fat fit to give you guys a
community to help you guys on your
weight loss journey now my channel can
only be here to give you guys a certain
amount of motivation after that it's all
on you you guys have to go ahead and
make the [ __ ] change once again in
these videos don't come to me asking me
how to do it
ask yourself how bad do you want what
are you going to do to get what you want
out of life and your health it does not
erase my friends its progress and a lot
of you out there need to focus on that
remember though at this moment you might
not be where you want to be but you're
still miles from where you were before
so funny fat fit fam remember life is
always what you make it but it's up to
you to take what you deserve let's go
for broke
[Music]
I'm gonna give you a quick rundown oops
don't know what funny fat fizz fizz kept
the countable and it wasn't man tell you
guys what the Beth met bet method it but
the madman it what the best with the
back way that's been